[Music]
good morning John it is Wednesday
September 13th thank you for answering
the question that I asked you no you
didn't you didn't you ignored my
question and then you ask me a question
so here I'm ignoring your question and
I'm going to read the first page of my
unpublished novel which is also
unfinished unrepresented and probably
will remain unpublished forever but
since you did it I'm doing it just the
first page what do you mean you don't
want bacon so I decided to start my book
bacon she was looking at him over her
shoulder shaking the pan over the burner
well it popped grease all over the stove
he was probably gonna have to clean that
up I just I don't know Mom we just don't
have bacon that's true they didn't in
fact they rarely ever ate meat at all
for both religious and financial reasons
meat hadn't been cheap since before
Danny was born but it was getting
cheaper things on the whole were getting
better but that doesn't mean we can have
bacon she was paying attention to meat
now but he could tell that she was
smirking if you wanted to be strict
about it though they couldn't have bacon
it's just he stammered he didn't want to
upset her she was obviously going
through a lot of trouble to make a nice
Sunday breakfast for the both of them
well there aren't a lot of slaughtered
pigs on the Buddha path mom he took his
turn smirking the Penan settled down on
the burner
Danny traced the wood grains in the
table with a knife that his mom had laid
out for the breakfast waiting for her
witty reply he looked up from the table
she was crying
no mom it's fine
I I love bacon it's just been a long
time he thought of a hundred ways to
sensibly in that sentence but none of
them came out she turned away and rested
her hands on the stove he was almost
used to it by now his mom had been
losing interest in religion finding bad
memories where Danny still managed to
find strength for more than a decade
she'd been a strict Buddhist since
before Danny was born since she met his
father but then it had been a long time
a long time since
seen him she pushed the fried bacon to
the backburner
walked to the refrigerator and took out
a tortilla and a can of cheap orange
juice the usual breakfast she put them
in front of Danny and swallowed her face
was red her eyes still wet she looked at
him hard and soft at the same time I've
been lying to you
what's Danny's mom been lying about tune
in next time to brother de voto to find
out okay not really
if that's not too annoying I wouldn't
mind finishing the chapter it's not very
long so let me know if you're at all
interested Alice for paper town the big
problem with the flashback as I saw it
is that I can't read the rest of the
book you're a jerk
there's gonna be all these people out
there and they're gonna have to wait
like a year before they find out what
the heck happened I'm having a hard time
waiting and I'm gonna get it like next
week huh
so yeah no problems except for the fact
that cliffhangers drive me crazy thank
you to everyone who took the time to
talk a little bit about their
experiences on September 11th it was
especially interesting to hear about
some people who were very young at that
time and who are not so young anymore
seven years is a long time Don I've been
noticing a lot of people asking you how
do you become a writer I'll just say
about that thing that I just wrote um
it's about a third of the way through
I'd say to being like a normal length
novel and I literally started by writing
down what do you mean you don't want
bacon because that seemed like a good
thing to say it's very much just like
exploring just like going on a walk
through the woods except you're in your
own brain don't worry about being a
writer or being a novelist just take a
walk in your brain or a bike ride in
your brick but don't drive because
that's bad for the environment I'll see
you tomorrow